a very good morning welcome to Sky News
breakfast thank you for joining us and
as I said we're starting with that
breaking news on the economy this
morning with the latest GDP figures for
the third quarter just released in the
last few moments and we have our
economics and data editor Ed Conway here
with us uh to tell us the news what are
they at yeah the economy has shrunk uh
by 0.2 percent in the third quarter uh
that is to take kind of the big picture
what is GDP it is the total amount of
income that we are generating across the
economy you know it's the that then gets
shared and goes into our pockets so the
fact that it's shrinking is obviously
not good news however 0.2 percent that
is actually a little bit a little bit
less bad than many economists had
expected they thought it was going to go
down by about 0.5
uh so this is a little bit better than
expected but even so it still suggests
we are in the beginning potentially of a
period of contraction and you know
people have been talking a lot about
recession recently haven't they well it
is it is a slightly arbitrary term but
basically it means when you've got two
excessive quarters so when we're talking
about quarters though three month
periods two successive quarters of the
economy shrinking that technically
constitutes a recession and the majority
of economists think next quarter we're
going to be shrinking potentially the
quarter after that as well so this may
well be the beginning of a period of the
economy shrinking but as I say that's
that number's actually a little bit
better than we expected so there's a
little glimmer of hope there and it's
worth also noting that that period I've
yet to see the full kind of details of
it because it's just coming but that
period obviously was the period of the
The Queen's funeral there was an extra
bank holiday in that period And when
there's an extra bank holiday that tends
to take a little bit off your output so
you know it may well be that adjusting
for that the economy was more like kind
of close to flatlining rather than going
down now this is not good news exactly
but it's certainly kind of less dire
than some people might have had you
believe does it suggest that perhaps the
recession that we're now going into may
end up being less Bleak than forecasts
previously by the bank of England well
let's hope so but I mean it's it's just
so hard to tell at the moment there's so
many importables right now I mean you
know whatever happens in Ukraine
whatever happens with Energy prices is
going to have a massive bearing on this
because to some extent that's you know
what we're adjusting to here higher
inflation higher energy prices and then
on top of that you've got the bank of
England adjusting to that raising
interest rates as well and then we're
expecting to hear from the government
next week about potential further
spending cuts so put all of that
together and you know it doesn't take an
economist to work out that all of that's
going to kind of dampen down the amount
of activity you have in the economy all
else equal I mean that you have less
spending but as I say a little bit it's
a kind of glimmer of slightly you know
less bad time yeah less blink than
expected and also worth setting that
against the fact that we just heard in
the US that inflation there is rising
less quickly than have been expected as
well still going up very fast but again
that people might put all this together
and say okay it's it's not going to be
easy it's going to be a very tough one
so there's all sorts of things you know
heading our way but maybe not quite as
bad as have been expected and in terms
of the Autumn statement next week could
could these figures impact what we may
hear from the chancellor it's it's hard
to tell I mean we're quite late on in
the process so probably they've started
to bed in a lot of their decisions we'll
get reaction from the chancellor to
these numbers I suspect that in a
perverse way they're quite Keen to
underline that you know it's tough times
at the moment and there are challenges
ahead but as I say it's worth saying
it's it's quite unusual to go into a
recession and to have the government
actually kind of pressing further on the
brake pedal which is kind of what's you
know that constitutes if you're cutting
spending if you're raising taxes that
makes it tougher so we will see and
we'll bring you more kind of details
about kind of what the breakdown it does
look like the services sector which is
the vast majority of the economy
actually kind of flatlining rather than
shrinking that's kind of relatively good
news and yeah 0.2 percent down a little
bit better than expected okay Ed for now
thank you